community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
all right the valley auto mall has a new
luxury dealership jc fernandez of course
dropped by
for a preview
[Music]
las vegas has a brand new jaguar land
rover dealership you want to see inside
come on
[Music]
tyler tyler you have outdone yourself
this place is gorgeous
yeah we're really proud of it you know
this is our this is our 33rd dealership
for the findlay automotive group you
know we started here
in las vegas with pete finley ozmobile
60 years ago
and we've grown a lot since then uh but
of those 33 dealerships
more than half of them are right here in
the las vegas valley and this is our
18th store in the las vegas area
so we're really proud of it it's also
our third jaguar land rover store
there's we have a jaguar land over reno
jaguar orlando over las vegas and now
finley's jaguar land rover henderson so
we're just thrilled to have the whole
state covered with these beautiful
vehicles
you really do and you know i think i've
been to the majority of your dealerships
here in las vegas obviously first time
here
in this one can you show me around yeah
yeah let's take a look around we're
sitting on five and a half acres of
prime real estate in the valley auto
mall
and we've built this beautiful new 32
000 square foot building we have
15 service bays here in the main shop uh
so you know great technology all the
latest all the electric chargers and
everything that you need
and then you couple it with the showroom
and a beautiful customer waiting area
and so forth
we're really really proud of this
facility i keep saying it's stunning
it's stunning lance
look at this because i feel like we can
actually probably eat off this floor
right now that's how clean your facility
is that's right
that's right and so i mean you buy a
luxury vehicle like a jaguar or land
rover
you want it to be in the best possible
place when it gets worked on and that's
what we've got here
tyler i do want to ask you because i'm
seeing in the news and stories when it
comes to
companies hiring employees do you guys
have a hard time finding employees
no and that's it's interesting because
we've opened a lot of stores and we do
the same thing every time we put all the
key positions and all the management
positions
we bring from other finley stores it
gives us a chance to advance people in
their careers
but also it makes sure that people get
the good customer experience that we
expect at findlay automotive
from right from the start they know what
uh how to treat people
and so and in fact in this store our
general manager
chuck luber comes from findlay honda how
about i introduce you to it
chuck congratulations on the new
dealership tell me how did you put your
team together
well uh i've spent 20 the last 20 years
at our finley honda store in the
northwest
quite a few of my management staff has
been with me most of that time
we've also obviously had a lot of
applicants
that looking forward to come to work
with us here
in henderson and we've picked some
people from the outside and
we've got a great staff ready to serve
the henderson las vegas valley well it's
a
gorgeous dealership but before i go um
tyler can i see a car
absolutely let's do it a 2021 defender
this is luxury this is power
tyler any closing words for us just uh
hey encourage everybody to come down to
the
valley auto mall and check out the new
jaguar land over henderson i'll tell you
what i'll buy you lunch if you let me
drive it
that's the deal all right let's go
and i will take that land over right
there